I like anything that stimulates my
imagination
vampire movies invite the realm of
fantasy or magic and so I always have
been a fan that's
been truly one of the highlights of my
career watching Nick Cage play Dracula
he had put a tremendous amount of work
into this character the level of effort
is staggering and our very first meeting
he was already getting into the body
movement and the true physicality of the
role I wanted to play with the movement
because that's a way into Dracula that
we haven't seen much
when you see cobras they try to seduce
you and then they try to hypnotize you
by moving like that and then go like
that and I wanted Dracula to have some
of that when I first saw Cage in the get
up I definitely got the chills he is
very scary
win these two elements of comedy and
horror will collide in such a way that
this one will be one of the memorable
Draculas
I am black
is it yummy yes
[Music]